más de un centenar de libaneses y
libanesas se han unido hoy para alzar su
voz y reclamar los derechos de la mujer
pero también en solidaridad con las
protestas por el deterioro de las
condiciones de vida de los libaneses que
desde hace una semana ha empeorado
después de que la libra libanesa haya
caído históricamente a una cotización de
10.000 libras libanesas por un dólar
esto sucede en medio de la pandemia por
el coronavirus donde el gobierno libanés
ha tenido que implementar medidas
estrictas como el cierre de todos los
comercios desde mediados de enero
después de casi dos meses de todos los
comercios cerrados la economía local se
ha visto gravemente afectada al igual
que los bolsillos de los libaneses que
han decidido salir a las calles para
mostrar su vida quemando contenedores
neumáticos levantando barricadas a la
crisis económica se une también la
inestabilidad política después de que no
haya habido un gobierno desde la
dimisión de hasan diab en agosto tras la
explosión del puerto de beirut y si no
hay un gobierno
y reformas económicas la pobre
internacional no va a apoyar al líbano y
esto solamente afecta más a los
libaneses